yeah dude you want to go nowhere who
who's the CEO of pelaton so now remember
where we started we started with Dana uh
asking Theo well who was The Advertiser
that said uh that if you put the RFK
interview up we're not going to
advertise you advertise you advertise
with you anymore well Theo actually did
remember and I'm pretty sure you've
heard of this company and I'm pretty
sure you should not buy their products
anymore go yeah I love that man yeah cuz
we had Robert Kennedy Jr on and we had a
company call or a couple companies call
after that and
say yeah just stuff about him we're not
advertising on this episode my
advertisers like you guys need to take
the episode Down oh pelaton was the we
just got an update um pel was the B was
the people who wanted an ad out pelaton
and meanwhile you have RFK so pelaton
yeah what do they sell fing bik the
stationary bikes yeah dude pellaton sell
stationary bikes and they got a problem
of Robert
Kennedy you pelaton what who the
are they yeah first right are youing
kidding me yeah yeah pelaton calling
about Robert
Kennedy yeah dude you want to go nowhere
who who's the CEO of pelaton huh I want
to see this gu I want to see this fing
lamb dude hey you know what gets you
further than pelaton hitchhiking okay
how about that
dude Barry mcth this fing weener snitel
huh let's see Barry McCarthy oh my
god oh yeah ohing yeah Barry McCarthy
looks like that guy 100% and look if
you're just listening at home and you're
thinking of what he looks like you're
right he looks like a douchebag yeah
dude 100% where's he from oh yeah he
looks like somebody that eats his own
skin a little bit at a time yeah he is
he is
a where is he he called me up and said
this guy was complaining about something
I'd say
oh San Francisco California there we go
my boy ring a ling dude go they've been
giving pellaton vagrant that's why
they're not leaving
yeah you pellaton yeah do we have patons
in the gym are those
pelaton asport no no there's bikes next
to it asport as yeah we're getting rid
of them y we're getting rid of the
patons yeah and if they ever m is going
to kill himself but we're getting rid of
the pelons he look pelons are out of the
gym whoever uses the most can have them
at home but they can't use them here
brother that's what you do that that's
what you do you stoping using their
products and you them yeah and tell
them to go themselves and that's
the same thing for me like if somebody's
telling you that you can't vote a
certain way if somebody's telling you
that if your boss is make a video and
fing blast imagine that fing dork yeah
picking up the phone calling you and
telling you that you you can't have
Robert Kennedy who is a Democrat by the
way you know that guy's aing Democrat
right telling you that you can't fing
have him on your show who the are you
Barry McCarthy yeah to think you can
pick up the phone and call anybody you
selling stationary bikes for a living
clown you yeah them dude god dude
and what is heing what is he he's
probably middleweight you can film us
yeah my my guys are going to take the
pelons out of the gym today love that
dude we're getting rid of them we're
going to go throw them in the
garbage today I'll be happy to toss them
in we're throwing the patons in the
garbage we're throwing them out of the
UFC gym I I'll be happy to toss them in
all right first off I did not know that
the F in Robert F Kennedy standed for
yeah but uh again Conor completely lost
control and we didn't blur any of that
beep any of that I'm sorry about that
really I'm trying to control the F bombs
and a lot I know a lot of you love it
when I curse and it's like this like
release of steam and everything else but
I know a lot of you are also watching
this there might be kids in the room and
everything else so we will try to
control that a bit more we just lost
control it was a lot it was a lot you
know you can only press that button so
many times before you start losing your
mind anyway you got the point what Dana
White is doing there fighting against
these advertisers saying I'm going to
get rid of my pelaton bikes right now
like that's what he said and theovon
calling out the advertisers for doing
that and then people that will go ahead
and build new things and UFC making a
deal with Rumble all of this stuff guys
that is the
chance